bonjour à tous bienvenue comme chaque
semaine on se retrouve pour parlement
hebdo refait l'actualité politique et
parlementaire bien évidemment avec
catherine d'heure bonjourbonjour michael
et nous accueillons cette semaine
laetitia avia vous êtes député de la 8e
circonscription de paris et membre du
bureau exécutif de la république en
marche
on va revenir avec vous sur plusieurs
actualités les nouvelles règles de
remboursement des frais de mandat
pas si vite la déontologue de
l'assemblée estime que le contrôle sera
un peu difficile
l'impôt prélevé directement sur le
salaire se sera réalité le 1er janvier
2019 la mesure qui fait partie du budget
rectificatif a été adopté et puis
l'hommage populaire à johnny hallyday
disparu dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi
émotion et ovations aussi à l'assemblée
depuis six avions va commencer donc par
la réforme de l'assemblée nationale
la déontologue de l'assemblée nationale
a poussé un cri d'alarmé
elle dit ne pas avoir les moyens de
vérifier notamment les notes de frais
des députés vous savez c'est une règle
qui a été mise en vigueur
et c'est trés guerre entre raul janvier
c'est une enquête menée par astrid de
vilaines philippe mathot stéphanie des
pierres dans cet avis confidentiel que
s'est procurée alcp la déontologue de
l'assemblée le dit sans détour elle n'a
pas les moyens de vérifier les frais de
mandat des députés comme le prévoit la
loi de moralisation de la vie publique
le dispositif retenu ne permettra pas la
déontologue de contrôler que les
dépenses des députés correspondent à des
frais de mandat comme le prescrit la loi
dans son rapport la déontologue pointe
du doigt une vérification partiel est
imparfaite seuls 120 députés par an
tirés au sort seront contrôlés dans le
nouveau système qui sera en vigueur le
1er janvier prochain
avertie par la déontologue la semaine
dernière françois de rugy assure avoir
pris en compte certaines de ses demandes
plusieurs de ces objections ont été
prises en compte et nous avons modifié
après deux heures de débats en réunion
de bureau un certain nombre de
dispositions qui ont trait à la fois aux
contrôles contre ces dessins la
principale objection de la déontologue
le contrôle des frênes mandat sera
assurée sur des bases claires la tenue
d'une comptabilité les justificatifs
mais le député charles de courson qu'il
a rencontré mardi matin
u17 vision la déontologue dit que le
système de contrôle de lierre et femmes
n'est absolument pas satisfaisante la
même point les moyens si vous voulez de
contrôler cent vingt 120 députés au sein
de la majorité les députés sont divisés
que on doivent justifier de nos frais
moi je trouve ça parfaitement normal
donc si la déontologue a besoin de
moyens
bref allez lui donnez nous les
parlementaires on est prêt je suis au
taquet les notes de frais dans ma poche
que je garde au jour le jour avec des
tickets de caisse pour ça tout à fait
normal j'ai fait même avant la réforme
après on va pas rentrer dans une
mécanique de sueur contrôle qui n'a
mènerait finalement qu'à dépenser
beaucoup d'argent de la république pour
vérifier que les gens sont
fondamentalement honnête
françois de rugy s'est donné un an pour
tester cette réforme avant de la
modifier si besoin est ici un cri de
colère cris d'alarmé en tout cas le
nepad et autonome vous étiez vous très
virulente dans l'hémicycle on se
rappelle vous vouliez vraiment qu on est
au bout du processus et fiable on se
retrouve avec un processus presque à
moitié à risque il faut voir le verre à
moitié vide à moitié plein dites nous
tout alors d'abord je soulignerai que
c'est un point d' alerte de la
déontologue et temples et c'est un point
d' alerte qui était antérieure à la
version définitive du dispositif
françois de rugy l'a rappelé après ce
point d' alerte un certain nombre
d'éléments ont été améliorés et il est
notamment préconisée et c'est vrai c'est
quelque chose moi que je recommande
également de faire appel à un expert
comptable pour tenir une comptabilité
précise vous avez pris d'emblée en
compte les remarques de la déontologue
vous avez exact réagissent et ça coûte
exactement elle a été consultée
c'est normal elle n'a pas les moyens à
elle seule de pouvoir contrôler une
comptabilité d'autres usages voilà est
d'autant plus que les députés n'ont pas
tous l'habitude heures nous qui vont de
la société civile c'est le vrai moi je
suis professions libérales je sais tenir
une comptabilité
je sais qu'à un certain nombre de mes
collègues n'ont pas l'habitude de tenir
cette comptabilité
il vaut mieux qu'il fasse appel à un
expert comptable qui va organiser cela
de manière claire et qui permettrait à
des autos l'heure de faire son travail
correct la réforme prévoit que 120
députés enfin une centaine de députés
soient tirés au sort qu est ce que vous
croyez laetitia via aux vertus du hasard
dans ce domaine vous savez ce hasard
c'est celui que vivent l'ensemble
aujourd'hui des chefs d'entreprise ou
des professions libérales le contrôle
de nos frais et de notre comptabilité
est également hasardeuse quand c'est un
contrôle fiscal
il ya la tenue de la comptabilité et
rigoureux il faut faire tous les ans
mais ensuite le contrôle c'est
hasardeuse et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
être toujours au clair et avoir une
stabilité à la comptabilité la plus
parfaite possible pour ne pas avoir de
contrôler et de régularisation après
vous on se souvient dans l'hémicycle
pendant ces nuits où l'assemblée a siégé
pour faire adopter les lois de
moralisation qui prévoient ces règles eh
bien vous souhaitiez un contrôle quand
même assez strictes que chaque dépense
finalement soit soit justifiée comme
cela oui comme ma gang en bretagne pas
en juin c'est long je le retrouve dans
le même système que celui que je vis
depuis huit ans que je suis avocate et
c'est exactement ce que j'ai dit dans
l'hémicycle
c'est que je ne vois pas pourquoi il y
aurait une différence entre un député
est une personne professions libérales
ou armes ont pris ce qu'ils doivent
justifier de ses frais depuis le 18 juin
depuis que je suis élu je garde
l'ensemble de mes factures
ce sera toujours le cas j'organise une
comptabilité cette comptabilité
peut-être vérifier c'est ça le plus
important c'est qu'il y ait un contrôle
et une obligation vraiment de justifier
de l'ensemble des frais loin de
moralisation qui faisait partie un petit
peu de tout ça des réformes voulues par
le président de l'assemblée nationale
suffisant aux yeux des français pour
approcher le politique et les français
selon vous vous savez il ya ça voulait
pas les notes de frais défiance
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de la sphère
politique on le sait et cet éloignement
il faut lutter contre 6 il faut aller
plus loin
moi je suis tout à fait volontaire
vraiment a pas apporté toujours un
système qui peut aller plus loin
françois doury j ai bien dit qu'il était
ouvert à une évaluation d'ici un an
juste et annonce on peut faire de plus
ce que c'est ça le plus important c'est
drôle
de rapprocher les citoyens voilà
exactement c'est l'élément le plus
important et s'il faut aller plus loin
dans un contrôle systématique avec
peut-être un service comptable plus
conséquent au sein de l'assemblée
peut-être pour aider à cela nous irait
bien oui je serai aux volontaires
vraiment pour porter également ses
réformes
là on va revoir une l'image qui a
beaucoup circulé sur les réseaux sociaux
le député françois ruffin vêtu d'un
maillot de foot à la tribune de
l'assemblée vous le voyez c'était ce
jeudi lors de l'examen d'un texte visant
à taxer les gros transferts de sportifs
professionnels
l'élu de la france sont soumises s'est
vu infliger une sanction financière pour
extravagances vestimentaires
il voulait porter un message politique
sur ce sur ce texte sur ce texte
ou est-ce que ça vous choque une
sanction ce que c'est adapté c'est ce
que la direction a justifié la sanction
est justifiée se tenir le choc
il ne faut pas oublier que nos
concitoyens travaille tous les jours
payent des impôts pour que nous soyons
dans cette assemblée nationale et que
nous travaillons tous les jours pour eux
et je pense que certaines manifestations
manque de respect envers cette
institution et par conséquent envers les
français
on est là dans la politique spectacle
qui ne respectent absolument pas le
règlement qui demande une tenue correcte
et digne le port de la cravate
ok c'était pas nécessaire alors vous
avez bien plus ce règlement juste avant
les allées la mer mais ça va ça vient
toujours du même parti exact l'histoire
de la cravate l'histoire du drapeau
d'istanbul au dos du maillot de fouilles
et la question c'est finalement que
va-t-il apporter à la souris avec te
ment la france insolence que volts il a
porté à sept à blanc est cette assemblée
nationale quel message veulent qu'il a
porté lors je ne comprends pas un vrai
manque de visibilité aujourd'hui
quant à leur objectif poli mais alors
justement là il y avait un message que
voulait porter françois ruffin il avait
mis ce maillot justement pour alerter
sur ces gros transfert qui on pourrait
taxer pour financer le
le foot amateur et m'a finalement il
dénonce une approche un peu lucratif du
sport donc ce message vous le n'at-il
pas des mots pour dénoncer cela n'est ce
pas le lieu notamment où les mots sont
là et ont un poids on vient passer un
message
oui nous sommes nous sommes nous sommes
législateur avant tout nous avons aussi
l'interdiction
c'est dans le règlement de brandir des
objets à plusieurs reprises la france
insoumise a brandi des objets dans
l'hémicycle il faudrait la langue et
c'est lorsque l'on fait la loi
il faut pouvoir en premier lieu la
respecter aujourd'hui la france
insoumise a tendance à ne pas respecter
le propre règlement de l'assemblée
nationale et je pense que lorsqu'on
parle de probité pour les français et
pour la vie politique il faut commencer
par soi même et donc il a eu une
sanction et son intelligence ul sera
diminué d'un quart pour ce mois ci alors
on va poursuivre avec le feu vert de
l'assemblée au prélèvement à la source
la mesure entrera en vigueur le 1er
janvier 2019 elle a été votée dans le
cadre d'un projet de loi de finances
rectificative adoption sous les
critiques de l'opposition de droite
notamment nathalie guille war je vais
mettre voir l'article 9 du projet de loi
à 65 voix contre 32 l'assemblée a voté
les nouvelles modalités du prélèvement à
la source un texte adopté après une
longue bataille des élus de droite
il estime que le dispositif pèsera sur
les entreprises et pénalisera certaines
catégories de contribuables
je pense qu'il ya dans cette réforme une
grande difficulté s'est pas transformé
les entreprises en collector c'est pas
des percepteurs d'impôts les entreprises
on se retrouve avec une vraie charge
supplémentaire qui me paraît totalement
et dui c'est pas leur coeur de métier
que de percevoir l'impôt et d'être
percepteur la gauche elle même à
quelques réserves sur cette mesure phare
du quinquennat de françois hollande
si l'impôt à la source permet la
progressivité de l'impôt il peut être
examinées avec bienveillance par nous
s'il permet de traiter à égalité des
contribuables qui sont dans des
situations différentes alors il aura
vocation à aggraver les inégalités
devant l'impôt ce que nous redoutons
fortement d argument que rejette la
majorité pour l'opposition a quant elle
était dans la majorité la majorité
d'entre eux étaient pour le prélèvement
à la source c'est comme l'éco taxe et
qu'ils ont mis en place et puis après
ils ont flingué là c'est pareil ils
étaient pour maintenant ils sont content
parce qu'il faut s'opposer
évidemment il ya les difficultés dont
qui monte en épingle toutes les
difficultés en oubliant l'intérêt
principal s'est luxé j'ai indiqué de
permettre aux plus modestes de madone
d'encaisser les variabilités de la vie
autre problème la confidentialité des
données
durant la séance le rapporteur joël
giraud apporter des amendements qui
permettrait d'aménager des sanctions cas
de divulgation d'une information fiscale
le sous-amendement précise que ces
sanctions s'appliquent à la violation du
secret professionnel mais aussi à un
usage qui est détourné du taux afin de
lever toute ambiguïté sur ce point le
prélèvement à la source entrerait en
vigueur le 1er janvier 2019 alors je
salue l'entrée sur ce plateau de jim
jarrassé qui va intervenir dans quelques
minutes aux deux partenaires du
figaro.fr laëtitia a via la droite
estime que le dispositif d'un point la
source est injuste et pas tout à fait
prêt est ce que vous redoutez
et un bug le 1er janvier 2019 tout cas
fin 2019 quand des millions de français
vont découvrir la nouvelle réalité de
leur fiche de paye pourquoi est ce que
cette mesure a été reporté au 1er
janvier 2019 justement pour prendre le
temps de la mettre en place de vérifier
justement qu'on va pouvoir l'appliquer
correctement
c'est pour ça qu'on n'avait pas en place
dès 1er janvier 2018 on a un peu plus
d'un an là pour travailler à sa mise en
oeuvre
et c'est justement pour éviter qu'il y
ait ces surprises que vous indiquez avec
un dispositif qui permet d'ailleurs une
expérimentation dès la rentrée 2010 8
enfin des mois de septembre 2018 pour
que nos concitoyens puissent voir sur
leur fiche de paie l'évolution est qu au
1er janvier 2019 il n'y est pas non plus
de changement drastique et choquant pour
toutes les misères du député tout à
l'heure tous et lapointe la source
on le reporte leurs portes tout cas
lorsqu'on ne reprendrait pas aux
calendes grecques pourquoi pas il part d
un autre exemple ça tout cela aura bien
du en 2019 fois par an sont retrouvés
deux jours on joue a été votée car êtes
vous fait pas de mis en oeuvre au 1er
janvier 2019 c'est très important pour
les français c'est eux et notamment pour
les plus modestes pour les classes
populaires pour les classes moyennes
aussi de pouvoir lisser une charge qui
est très importante et de pouvoir aussi
adapté l'impôt à leur mode de vie
aujourd'hui on a des difficultés à payer
un impôt qui est calculé sur des revenus
qui était antérieur litres alors la
priorité ce sont les français vous savez
confié au sénat on examine en ce moment
le budget sera voté avant le 12 décembre
prochain
il a été largement détricoté par rapport
à ce que vous avez présenté la
république en marche et ce qui a été
voté à l'habitude que d'habitude moi non
et pourtant et pourtant emmanuel macron
se disait et de droite et de gauche
il n'y a pas de consensus possible avec
adria il y à il ya des consensus et on a
pu voir dans quête de la loi de
confiance par exemple que nous serons
ravis
pendant ces le budget oui mais on a
certains éléments sur lesquels il ya
aussi une position conservatrice une
voilà une peut-être une absence de
volonté de voir les choses évoluer
nous portons un projet progressiste nous
portons un projet pour les français pour
améliorer le quotidien des français le
prélèvement à la source en fait partie
alors sur le budget donc 12 décembre
vote au sénat
et après commission de conciliation
députés sénateurs pour trouver un texte
commun on prévoit déjà un échec est ce
que vous prévoyez donc il y aura un vote
forcé de l'assemblée dans la dernière
semaine de noël
sur ce premier budget du quinquennat ce
n'est pas un vote fort c'est un dernier
mot donné à l'assemblée elle durera etc
et c'est la règle de nos institutions
ça a déjà été le cas sur d'autres textes
on revient à l'assemblée pour voter
cette mesure il nous en prenons toute la
responsabilité vous verrez peut-être et
peut-être des choses à premier côté du
cdn il ya peut-être il y aura la lettre
a dit oui mais là pas de remise en cause
du système
en tout cas et du principe même de me
les vents à la source ces partis
d'autres avis du figaro est avec nous
jim jarrassé
gym c'est un mot qui râlent bonjour
katia bon choix laetitia avia vous
occuper une place importante au sein du
bureau exécutif de la république en
marché un des défis qui vous qui vous
attendent bien cette fixé une ligne
claire pour le parti qui soit pas
forcément le simple soutien au
gouvernement
il ya une enquête ipsos qui a été
publiée cette semaine dans le monde et
qui dit que 55% des français pensent que
l om est un mouvement de droite
est ce que cette perception vous
surprend et chihab ya ça ne me surprend
pas parce que on est dans une séquence
aujourd'hui ils ont mis en oeuvre un
certain nombre de mesures qui sont
étiquetés de droite
ensuite moi j'ai une grille de lecture
oui c'est toutes les mesures qui vont
aujourd'hui vers une libération
finalement de l'investissement pour
pouvoir
c'est la seconde séquence pouvoir mieux
protéger les plus faibles
donc oui on a on est de gauche et de
droite donc un certain nombre de mesures
peuvent paraître comme étant plus de
droite de droite mais il faut il faut
regarder la globalité et c'est vraiment
cela que nous portons c'est un système
global où on libère et on protège nous
dit c'est que c'est seulement à la fin
de l'action note emmanuel okon la fin du
quinquennat qu'on pourra juger de cette
ligne politique
le programme était prévu justement sur
un mandat entier de cinq ans l'ensemble
du budget aussi un budget qui est cadrée
sur cinq ans la plupart de nos mesures
comprennent dans une vraiment un
calendrier de ce que tu étais un peu
c'est un 2e mandat peut-être pour
prolonger cette action
bien sûr que je le souhaite on n'est pas
encore là aujourd'hui du programme mais
oui c'est hélas les chorales celle du
parti c'est ce que vous préparez la
transformation la transformation du pays
ne se fera pas qu'en cinq ans mais une
forte impulsion sera fait déjà dans les
18 prochains mois
un petit mot sur la laïcité emmanuel
macron devait recevoir ce vendredi les
représentants des cultes la réunion
était reportée pour raisons d'agenda
est-ce que sur le sujet brûlant de la
laïcité la parole du chef de l'état est
attendu
je pense que la parole des maniaques -
est attendue des français qui ont besoin
peut-être deux
clarification quant à nos sion de
laïcité est ce qu'elle représente au
quotidien salue on est sur les textes
sont clairs il n'est pas question
aujourd'hui de les faire évoluer
nous on est sur les textes de 1905 qui
ne correspondent pas à la réalité de
notre société aujourd'hui en 2000 à 17
ans qui enfin ça correspond pas est ce
qu'il faut faire c'est surtout montré
l'application concrète
voilà à notre société aujourd'hui de
cette loi est simplement chez s'empêcher
marché l'idée ce n'est pas de tuer est
absolument pas la laïcité elle est là et
elle correspond aux fondamentaux de
notre société ce sujet les il faut
absolument pour les français aujourd'hui
l'illustré voilà par leur quotidien sur
ce sujet il ya un député qui est qui est
proche de votre groupe qui a eu des
prises de positions très marquée c'est
manuel valls sur ce qu'il appelle les
islamo gauchiste est ce qu'il est allé
trop loin selon vous sur le sur le sujet
vous savez manuel valls a toujours eu
une position assez claire sur ce sujet
ce qui nous a pas empêchés de l'intégrer
au sein du groupe la république en
marche cette position n'est pas ça la
république en marche n'a jamais et à
salir minutes en marche
d'accord mais ça vous gêne quelque peu
ça nous on s'est connus il tenait
toujours été que lorsque chacun chacun
peut s'exprimer
n'est ce n'est pas la position de la
république en marche et je pense que nos
concitoyens le savent très bien et c'est
ça le plus important qu'il n'y ait pas
de confusion
laurent wauquiez va probablement devenir
dimanche soir le nouveau leader de la
droite est ce que c'est le retour d'une
opposition de droite pour la république
est en marche face à la république en
marche j'ai je pense pas qu'il y ait de
disparition des oppositions
nous passons nous la droite était un peu
dans une phase de reconstruction et de
redéfinition suite à la défaite de
présidentiable le plus important pour la
république en marche c'est
l'application de notre programme et
surtout ce que vous indiquez en propre
au préalable mais sur l'eau revient
aussi qu emmanuel macron me voit déjà
arriver peut-être l'un de ses
principales au poteau pour la future
élection partielle doit le premier
proposant là forcément vous savez moi je
regarde toutes les oppositions et je ne
nierai pas considérer que seuls les
républicains seul laurent wauquiez
seraient à même d'être une opposition
sud in je pense que ce serait vraiment
une erreur de fonctionner ainsi
et on regarde toutes les oppositions et
de chaque extrait nous reste une demi
lune à la dernière question vous faites
partie avec d'autres députés d'un groupe
de travail sur le harcèlement de rue qui
a été lancé en septembre
est-ce que vous pouvez un peu nous dire
où vous en êtes sûr sujet sur la
verbalisation et ne se délite il n'en
est pas vraiment une puisqu'il n'est pas
qu'ils n'en aient pas il n'est pas
défini dans la loi c'est définir donc on
a avancé on est sur une rédaction d'un
texte qui verbalisent re l outrage
sexistes fin décembre voire début
janvier pour qu'ils puissent être
portées dans le cadre des lois tout ça
c'est un rapport c'est pas en trop loin
c'est un rapport qui propose
une un texte pour une nouvelle
infraction qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui
qui serait donc codifie sainte
s'intégrer dans quelle loi dans un
projet de loi dans le projet de loi qui
sera porté par marlène schiappa sur ce
thème précis sur ce thème sur les
violences sexistes et sexuelles
également donc la présomption de non
consentement et la presqu'île et
l'allongement de la prescription sur les
viols sur mineurs également merci jeeves
arras et on va terminer cette émission
avec l'hommage les hommages unanimes à
johnny hallyday
à l'assemblée les députés se sont levés
mercredi en séance pour rendre hommage
au chanteur disparu regard des jeux
s'est exprimé votre sentiment en disant
que à l'image des françaises et des
français
nous avons tous en nous quelque chose de
johnny hallyday
et vous vous garderez quoi de johnny
laeticia via sa vie fait partie de notre
patrimoine culturel c'est quelqu'un qui
a su toucher je pense tous les français
moi je suis né en 1985
c'est l'année de sa collaboration avec
michel berger
j'ai n'ai jamais beaucoup justement
lorsqu'il avait aussi ses chansons très
douce mais fortes et intenses
voilà je trouve qu'il a il avait un
panel qui permettait de toucher tous les
français et c'est ce que je retiendrai
la représentation nationale se lève à
l'unisson c'est comme ça c'est justement
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui touche tous
les français de gauche de droite est
assez rare classe de toutes les classes
sociales également et ce qu'on a pu
ressentir ces derniers jours c'est
surtout une émotion collective à suite à
son décès et c'est vraiment ce qui
montre aussi la beauté de ce qu'il a
apporté les jeunes est vide et c'était
aussi une histoire avec les hommes et
les femmes politiques c'est un sujet de
résultats' johnny hallyday 60 ans de
carrière plus de 1000 chansons
enregistrées mais seulement une engagé
politiquement
cheveux longs et idées courtes sorties
en 66 dans laquelle il se moque du
mouvement hippie
aguer toit rabaissé
assis sur son derrière
avec les bras croisés
on décèle déjà une sensibilité de droite
chez l'idole des jeunes
imprégné de libéralisme américain mais
il faudra attendre 1974 pour le voir
afficher son soutien à un homme
politique
quatre jours avant l'élection
présidentielle il vient offrir en
personne du muguet à anne aymone giscard
d'estaing il arbore le t-shirt giscard à
la barre des soutiens de vge en 1988 il
chante en première partie d'un meeting
géant de jacques chirac devant une
centaine de milliers de militants il
déclare le monstre de la chanson
française populaire un prestigieux
soutiens plus tard on le verra très
proche d'un autre homme politique de
droite nicolas sarkozy
c'est d'ailleurs lui qui le mari à
laëtitia le couple fait aussi partie de
ses invités au fouquet's ce soir de 2007
où il devient président
le chanteur soutient ses amies de droite
mais ne critique jamais le pouvoir quand
il est aux mains de la gauche
et parfois il cultive même le paradoxe
en 1985 et 1991 il chante à la fête de
l'huma
je ne vois pas pourquoi je ne chanterai
pas dans une fête du parti communiste je
n'ai rien contre les gens du parti
communiste avant tout je chante pour les
français et jusqu'à preuve du contraire
ce sont des français qui viennent voir
le spectacle
ces dernières années le chanteur étaient
désabusés par la politique
il n'a jamais caché son amitié avec
emmanuel macron rencontré par
l'intermédiaire de line renaud
mais à aucun moment il n'a appelé à
voter pour lui
cinquième est pas appelé à voter manuel
macro mais on se souvient nous qu'on a
vu dans ce reportage des images avec
giscard d'estaing ou et jacques chirac
sensibilité de droite c'est quelque
chose qu'ils font bon ménage aujourd'hui
les stars la politique phare du showbiz
se retrouve en effet dansez dansez et
même mieux parce que ce que je retiens
c'est qu'il a été comme beaucoup de
français d abuser de la politique et
et que s'ils voulaient oui comme comme
beaucoup de france on l'a vu sur libre
qui touche aussi beaucoup de français
parce qu'il vit il vit la même chose
voilà nous n'avons pas eu le temps de le
mettre en marche mais voilà je vous
donnerai partie de ce qu'il aurait fallu
renchérir on sait voilà il fait partie
de ceux qu'il aurait fallu reconquérir
justement c'est notre objectif
l'objectif que vous proposez aujourd'hui
c'est doit aussi de passer par ces
personnalités populaires par toute
personne ces personnalités populaires
ces personnes et politiques ces
personnes qui viennent de la société
civile qui sont inconnus et qui vont
parler un maximum de nos concitoyens
pour parce qu'on a besoin aussi de
s'identifier mieux alors on a longtemps
joui tic injustement l'hommage qui a été
choisie c'est un hommage populaire pour
johnny hallyday c'était la bonne formule
pour vous on a beaucoup hésité sur la
forme
oui je pense vous répondra par une
fallait absolument pas dommage
confidentiel pour quelqu'un qui
représentait temps pour tellement
français je pense que on a besoin
d'avoir un hommage qui représente
justement son oeuvre et sa proximité
avec les français
et en quelques secondes une pensée
également pour jour dans le son dans
moscou johnny hallyday de france qui se
parlent de deux personnes dont la
jeunesse aussi des mots nous manquons
beaucoup merci beaucoup laetitia lmia ce
sera laetitia via pardon ce sera le mot
de la fin
on termine cette émission rendez vous la
semaine prochaine même lieu même heure
par semaine à tous